hi I'm Toshiko Mori I'm an architect
really upset and I also teach and have a
design school what's interesting about
is why can't we can buy on the problems
together for multiscale multitasking
strategies for example one of the
important things we talk here is about
climate change but no one is giving an
incentive to the body of cover I have a
go team that lets go is a random metal
but it's given them a standard it's
given a value why can't we give a novel
about you to make a newsstand capture so
that there will be a new currency
because you already exist new economy
you to promote green economy as in the
Senate because new jobs and also a new
field of education for you let's say if
they recover is valued there may be a
way to play games and there we are
educational games in which a violence
can be defined as destruction of pet
instead of destruction human lives which
self-objectification can we turn it
around and I think it's a time for a
revolution as industrial illusions of
evolution is a time in which we can use
social networker to understand the value
and from what the value of carbon in the
air for promoting importance of
environment with it comes a job to the
US education in technological advances
multifaceted modulate modest scale so
that's the way to go for new reality
thank you